nos acompaña entran 24 guillermo carmona
el secretario de malvinas antártida y el
atlántico sur de argentina y vamos a
conversar en el contexto del 40
aniversario de la guerra que enfrentó a
argentina y a reino unido entre el 2 de
abril y el 14 de junio de 1982 por la
soberanía de las islas malvinas que los
británicos llaman falklands muchas
gracias por acompañarnos gracias a
ustedes un gusto
si para reino unido en la fecha del 14
de julio es un día de celebración de
hecho en las propias islas las llaman
celebration day liberation day el día de
la liberación porque es la fecha en el
que ganaron la guerra y que representa
esta fecha aquí para argentino y para
los argentinos
este año
estamos conmemorando los 40 años de la
guerra nosotros creemos que en una
guerra nunca hay nada para celebrar y
nos parece fundamental el hecho de poner
en el contexto crítico que significó
esta guerra de malvinas para la
argentina significó el fallecimiento de
más de 600 compatriotas también bajas
importantes en el reino unido- y las
consecuencias de una guerra no deberían
ser motivo de celebración
si para nosotros el 14 de junio comenzó
el 14 de junio de 1982 una etapa de
fuerte acción diplomática de la
argentina en función de lograr el
objetivo de la recuperación de ejercicio
de soberanía por la vía del derecho
internacional retomando lo que los
gobiernos argentinos antes de 1982
habían sostenidas desde una acción
constante diplomática a partir de los
argumentos geográficos históricos y
jurídicos que tiene la argentina en
función del objetivo de recuperar el
ejercicio pleno de soberanía
sobre malvinas también para nosotros el
mes de junio es un mes especial porque
recordamos la creación de la comandancia
político militar
de malvinas el 10 de junio por lo tanto
nuestra énfasis está puesto en esa fecha
en una fecha de reafirmación de la
soberanía argentina sobre malvinas eso
en que ello fue en 1829 es cuando se
crea la comandancia político militar a
cargo de la cual estuvo luís garnett
hay que tener en cuenta que ya desde
1810 cuando se produce el comienzo del
proceso de independencia de argentina
argentina tuvo una presencia efectiva y
tomó decisiones sobre malvinas los
gobiernos argentinos lo hicieron y en
1833 se produjo la usurpación es decir 4
años después de la creación de la
comandancia político militar a la
situación británica ha partido una
invasión militar británica sobre
malvinas y más allá de las fechas en
argentina que es lo más importante que
ha ocurrido hasta ahora en año especial
de 40 años de aniversario de la guerra
que se ha que se ha hecho que a usted
por lo menos le parece que es lo central
en primer lugar hemos reconocido a
nuestros veteranos y veteranas de guerra
ya hemos homenajeado los caídos en la
guerra de malvinas tenemos una deuda de
gratitud hacia ellos ellos no decidieron
hacer la guerra no tomaron decisiones
políticas ni militares esas decisiones
políticas de militares la toma una
dictadura cívico-militar y por lo tanto
aquellos que cumplieron con su deber con
la patria el reconocimiento es muy
importante pero junto con eso en segundo
lugar destacó que argentina está
desarrollando un gran despliegue
diplomático en todo el mundo
especialmente en los foros
internacionales en naciones unidas en
función del objetivo de retomar las
negociaciones con el reino unido- que
quedaron congeladas por decisión
unilateral del reino unido- antes del
comienzo de la guerra de malvinas y
además está muy reactivo el estado
argentino a todo lo vinculado con
malvinas recientemente reino unido
declaró ciudad a puerto argentino port
stanley hubo unas reacciones también
también del argentino porque es un
problema eso
la argentina no no actuar reactivamente
la argentina lo que hace es
señalar los casos en los cuales se está
violando el derecho internacional que el
reino unido está violando el derecho
internacional en este caso particular
que la monarca británica tome una
decisión respecto de
una población que se encuentra en el
territorio argentino e implica un acto
unilateral por parte del gobierno
británico en función de este algo que
impactan en el territorio argentino que
está usurpado y ese tipo de situaciones
argentina las está reclama
internacionalmente como fue en este caso
y el contexto internacional actual con
la crisis post pandemia todavía no
podemos decir por pandemia pero casi la
crisis de guerra en europa
lo vuelve más favorable a una resolución
o dificulta más las cosas hay tres
condiciones que son muy favorables para
la argentina en este momento la primera
condición tiene que ver con que
la política británica muestra
fuertes situaciones críticas no hay
tendencias e incluso secesionistas
dentro del propio reuniones como en el
caso de irlanda del norte o el caso de
escocia en segundo lugar hay una
situación provocada por el break sheet
de debilidad
del reino unido en su posición respecto
del resto de europa y en tercer lugar
nunca desde que yo tengo memoria se ha
hablado tanto de la integridad
territorial de los estados como ahora
con lo que está pasando en ucrania el
reino unido reclama este que se respete
la integridad territorial de ucrania y
está muy bien que lo haga argentina
también lo hace el gobierno argentino lo
hace ahora ese mismo este gobierno
británico que reclama por la integridad
territorial
viola sistemáticamente la integridad
territorial argentina esta situación es
una situación que hoy está muy en el
mundo y que le ofrece a la argentina una
oportunidad de pararse en un lugar de
fortaleza en su reclamo de negociación
es la última de las tres que mencionó me
queda muy clara las dos primeras
entiendo la debilidad unitaria no
entiendo cómo eso se puede capitalizar
como fortalezas argentinas a la hora de
presionar por un cambio en el status quo
pareciera ser que el gobierno británico
tiene dificultades para mantener la
unidad del reino esté bueno esas
situaciones generan contextos también
las
fortalezas o debilidades internas que
tienen los estados son fundamentales al
momento de los procesos de
descolonización doy algunos ejemplos
tras la segunda guerra mundial
una gran bretaña exhausta por las
consecuencias de la guerra tuvo que
afrontar la realidad de favorecer
procesos de descolonización en áfrica y
asia este en ese mismo marco estaba
malvinas también los procesos de
descolonización e
incluso hubo decisiones británicas que
favorecían la posibilidad un
entendimiento con la argentina entre
1905 y mil 982 así que las condiciones
internas de los estados también son
importantes para la resolución de este
tipo de situaciones de controversias y
respecto al break seal y al estado y al
estatus del reino unido respecto vía
europea ha habido algún tipo de
acercamiento a algún país europeo dando
mayor respaldo del de la habitual
argentina en este momento el reclamo
tenemos por un lado
una situación de partida que es que
malvinas ya no es considerado como
territorio de ultramar británico este al
momento de la relación entre gran
bretaña y la unión europea primera
cuestión segunda cuestión hay una
y acción diplomática
persistente de la argentina para sumar
apoyos en la unión europea yo de hecho
he participado en encuentros con
funcionarios y parlamentarios europeos
en función de crear condiciones
favorables para apoyos hacia la
argentina el 18 de mayo se realizó el
censo aquí en argentina
y para argentinas marinas es un
territorio de pertenece al país se pudo
contar a los habitantes de se habilitó
la posibilidad de descenso tanto en la
antártida argentina como en las islas
malvinas georgias del sur y sándwich del
sur como corresponde es parte del
territorio nacional
lógicamente allí hay una dificultad
operativa para verificar datos
estamos trabajando con el indec que es
el organismo que hace las muestras
censales a los efectos de todo aquello
que se pueda contabilizar se contabilice
por ejemplo la cantidad de viviendas que
hay en malvinas a partir de información
satelital ese es uno de los elementos
que estamos trabajando en por supuesto
los censistas no podían ingresar a
malvinas como nos hubiera gustado y
hubiera correspondido pero este sí se
hicieron los actos útiles para que eso
fuera posible el censo en la
habilitación del censo virtual este era
el acto útil que como gesto de soberanía
argentina tenía que realizar y alguien
lo completó no tenemos información al
respecto por último algunos algunos
argumentan que que si argentina se
volviera más atractivo para los isleños
señalando que es un país con
persistentes crisis que dificultades
sobre todo con las cuestiones económicas
y mantener una economía estable
sería más fácil que los niños se
interesaran
en acercarse sé que la posición
argentina no es de negociar con los
isleños sino con reino unido pero no sé
qué opina de quienes piensan de esa
manera
quienes opinan de esa manera no tienen
en cuenta qué
[Música]
en gran bretaña es un país con
persistentes crisis
la mitad está viviendo un momento
económico muy importante hace poco
supimos que una parte
sustancial de la población
británica éste tiene una comida al día
y hemos sabido también de las
dificultades presupuestarias que tienen
provocadas entre otras cosas por los
efectos de la guerra en ucrania
así que
vivimos en un mundo en crisis la
situación
argentina está enmarcada en ese mundo en
crisis del cual también es parte gran
bretaña segundo lugar argentina un país
muy atractivo es un país atractivo para
quienes
hablan otro idioma tienen otra cultura
argentina ha sido un país de brazos
abiertos y yo no tengo la menor duda de
que en la medida en que
el reino unido- el gobierno británico
deje de bloquear la posibilidad de
vínculos de los isleños con el
territorio continental argentino
esos aspectos atractivos van a
predominar el fútbol nuestra música
nuestra cultura las universidades
algunos preguntan que tiene para ofrecer
argentina y universidad gratuita salud
gratuita posibilidades de cultura en
grandes ciudades
posibilidades de lugares tranquilos para
disfrutar del turismo argentina tiene
mucho mucho para ofrecer a quienes viven
en las islas como lo ha hecho con este
personas y familias que se han radicado
en nuestro territorio nacional teniendo
otras costumbres teniendo otra cultura y
otro idioma
guillermo carmona muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos en las gracias a ustedes
por acompañarnos en france 24 los invito
a seguir nuestra programación y nuestros
contenidos en france 24 punto com
[Música]